second in line to the u.s presidency
nancy pelosi is the highest ranking u.s
official to visit ukraine the speaker of
the house led a congressional delegation
to keeve and spent three hours with the
ukrainian president vladimir zelinsky do
not be bullied by bullies if they're
making threats you cannot back down
that's my view of it that you
we're there for the fight
and you cannot
you cannot
fold to a bully
the u.s delegation discussed the big
three issues for the ukrainians security
humanitarian support and financial aid
we need this bill to support ukraine in
this fight for freedom president joe
biden has already announced a new 33
billion dollar aid package senate leader
chuck schumer says they're going after
russian president vladimir putin's
friends and allies in the legislation of
the 33 billion i will be adding
provisions that allow us to go after the
oligarchs
take their money
and send it right to ukraine
this is the kind of stuff we're talking
about
yachts
mansions
at the moment the us can seize assets
and freeze them new legislation would
make it easier to seize and sell
funneling the money back to ukraine it's
a tactic used against organized crime in
the us there will be processes and
protections in place to prevent
unwarranted seizures
one of the things that schumer and his
team are talking about are having an
expedited
review process so that any appeals
could be made
quickly the senate could start moves on
the new aid package this week the house
is on a break but could push through any
legislation quickly with the support
from both parties joe biden could have
built a sign within two weeks alan
fisher al jazeera washington